hi I'm Craig calendar I'm professor of
philosophy at the University of
California San Diego I'm a philosopher
of science specializing in foundations
of physics and other areas of philosophy
of science
people tend to link black holes with
thermodynamics due to arguments by
physicists in the early 1970s back then
they noticed that there were these
connections where black holes looked a
lot like thermodynamic systems they
could be described by a very small
number of parameters just like say a gas
in the box
you know it's described by pressure
volume and temperature the black hole
could be described by just a few
parameters - and the thought - would be
that they would settle into a natural
equilibrium State just like in
thermodynamics so these arguments were
very powerful and they helped derive
this whole field of black hole
thermodynamics
analogies and physics can be very useful
the history of physics is littered with
analogies that have been very successful
it's also been littered with analogies
they've not been so successful when it
comes to black holes and thermally
mimics though it's not just that people
think that there's an analogy they think
that there's an identity that black
holes just are you know the principles
of black holes just are thermodynamic
principles and it's that identity that
makes me worry so I don't think that the
idea the arguments for the identity are
that strong in particular I think that
they all rely on understanding the
dynamic entropy in the subjective way as
a subjective notion of entropy I don't
think that's right so there might so the
analogy might be good when it comes to a
kind of information theoretic entropy
our subjective entropy but I don't think
it really is that they really are
thermal image
and trying to find a theory of quantum
gravity it's very difficult and we're
looking for clues and hints wherever we
can get them Michel temer Amex is often
advertised as the main clue for it there
if quantum gravity but with everybody
all in on that there's not room for
competing viewpoints where that doesn't
don't rely on the analogy being an
identity as opposed to just an analogy
and I think we should be open to
different viewpoints where we think that
black hole thermodynamics is just a nice
analogy and not an identity
yeah so it's supposed to be a perpetual
motion machine and then in surviving
documents it says it worked in the
presence of the king and otherwise and
the idea is that there's and in fact it
gets starts to go backwards